a pivoted rod held horizontal parallel
to the ground and released from rest
will simply fall rotating about the
pivot point in particular suppose we
have a mass attached to one end of a
pivoted rod so here's my pivot here's my
pivoted rod which we'll assume is
massless and I have and it has a length
D and I attached a mass M to one end if
I let this go from rest it will simply
fall rotating about the pivot point
which I'll call s and it's easy to
understand that in terms of the action
of gravity which is acting downwards and
the resulting torque about point s if I
replace this point mass with a wheel of
the same mass so in this disk is a wheel
with let's say a radius R and the same
mass M attached to a pivoted rod the rod
is massless and has length D if I hold
this horizontal parallel to the ground
and release it from rest it will still
just fall to the ground not a surprising
result
what is surprising is if I then spin up
the wheel so if I have the wheel on
rotating about its axle with some large
angular velocity little Omega and then I
hold it horizontal parallel to the
ground and release it from rest then
remarkably this wheel Plus axle will not
fall it will remain horizontal parallel
to the ground but the center of mass of
the wheel will execute a small circular
orbit about the vertical axis through
the pivot point
you
this remarkable and very non-intuitive
motion is called precession and the
system that's undergoing precession is
called a gyroscope let's see if we can
understand this behavior in terms of the
angular momentum of the system so what
I've drawn here is a side view of the
system so let's define some coordinates
so we have our hat in the radial outward
Direction K hat in the direction of the
z axis the vertical axis and then we'll
define theta hat pointing into the
screen okay so that's a side view I'd
like to now draw a top view so let's say
we're looking down along the z axis from
the top on the system so now here's my
pivot point and here is a top view of my
wheel okay again this is a distance D
now this is still the R hat direction
this is the theta hat direction and the
K hat direction is pointing out of the
screen let's draw the forces acting on
our diagram here so the weight is acting
at the center of mass of the wheel
that's mg downward and there's a normal
force acting upwards at the pivot point
the torque is just given by R cross F
and so relative to point s at the
distance D times the weight mg so the
torque is mg D and by doing R cross F
with the right hand rule we see that
it's directed in the plus theta hat
direction now again let's suppose that
I'm holding the wheel horizontal and
release it from rest if the wheel is not
spinning okay so this is not rotating
this is a stationary wheel that I'm
holding horizontal and I release it from
rest
then its initial angular momentum with
respect to point s is zero over a short
time interval delta T the torque which
is acting in the theta hat direction
will cause an angular impulse or change
in the angular momentum that change in
angular momentum Delta L vector is equal
to the torque times that short time
interval delta T and it will act in the
theta hat direction the change in
angular momentum will be in the theta
hat direction because that's the
direction of the torque is in so for
this case and and by the way this view
here I should have labeled is this is a
top view so this is the side view this
is the top view of the same system so
the torque is mg D in the theta hat
direction so in the side view that's
going into the screen and in the in the
top view that's going pointing upward of
the theta hat direction so in the case
where the wheel is not spinning if we
think about the top view the initial
angular momentum is zero right so I'll
just draw that as a dot so that's L
initial equals zero and then I add a
small torque or small angular impulse
due to the torque Delta L which is in
the theta hat direction
so that's pointing in the theta hat
direction okay so that's my Delta L and
when I sum those together I start out
with 0 I add a small Delta L so my final
and going to momentum a time delta T
later is just equal to my Delta L so
this is L final and that's pointing in
the theta hat direction so a torque in
the theta hat direction into the screen
for the side view is consistent with the
wheel falling down so with theta hat
pointing into the screen the wheel will
basically fall
this way it's rotating about point s and
that's consistent with the torque
pointing in the theta hat direction
now as the wheel Falls the torque
continues to point in the theta hat
direction and so the angular
acceleration will increase now what
happens if this wheel is not stationary
but instead is spinning rapidly in that
case the torque remains the same it's
still mg d in the theta hat direction
but now the initial angular momentum is
not zero rather it is a very large
vector pointing along the spin axis
let's choose the sense of rotation such
that L points in the plus R hat
direction that's actually the way I've
drawn it here so in that case the
angular momentum vector initially points
in the plus R hat direction
so then what happens over a short time
delta T so now let's consider the case
where the wheel is spinning so now my
initial angular momentum is a large
vector pointing in the r hat direction
that's l initial i'm adding a small
perpendicular vector Delta L in the
theta hat direction and so the sum of
those two things if this is the original
r hat direction what's happened is that
my new vector is at a small angle with
respect to the original ER hat direction
I'll call that angle Delta Theta so what
I've done is I've rotated my initial
angular momentum vector by a small angle
without changing its length okay notice
the two very different situations in one
case I start out with zero angular
momentum and all the angular momentum I
end up with comes from the angular
impulse due to the torque in the second
case where the wheel is spinning I start
out with a very large initial angular
momentum I then add in
the small angular impulse small compared
to my initial angular momentum in the
perpendicular direction and that causes
not a change in the length of the vector
but a change in its direction which
means that the angular momentum vector
rotates that's why the system processes
when the wheel is rotating rapidly
before we can understand precession more
carefully it will be useful to review
the mathematics of rotating vectors so
first suppose we have a vector that I'll
call r1 and I'm going to add a vector
Delta R to this and I'm going to have
the condition that the length of Delta R
is much much smaller than the length of
my original vector r1 and that Delta R
is perpendicular is perpendicular to R 1
so here's my Delta R and so if I add
these two vectors let's say r2 is the
sum of r1 plus Delta R so that's my
vector r2 and I'm going to call this
angle Delta Theta and now a few things
to note first of all this is a right
triangle notice that the length r2 is
equal to r1 divided by the cosine of
Delta Theta but if that angle is small
if Delta Theta is a small angle then
cosine theta is well approximated by one
and so this is just my original length R
1 and since r1 is equal to r2 I'm just
going to call that call them both R and
this is for small
delta theta okay so that tells us that
the vector just rotates when I have a
large vector and I add a small
perpendicular vector the result is to
rotate the original vector without
changing its length as long as the angle
is small or equivalently as long as
Delta R is very small compared to my
original vector length I'll get a pure
rotation in addition again looking at
this triangle notice that Delta R is
equal to which I can just write as R
times the sine of Delta Theta and again
if the angle is small of data if Delta
Theta is a small angle then this is well
approximated by R times the angle Delta
Theta in radians and again this is for
small Delta Theta so now if I divide
this last equation by delta T a small
time interval in which this rotation is
happening then I write this is Delta R
vector divided by delta T and I take the
magnitude of that that is equal to R
Delta Theta divided by delta T and if I
go to the limit as delta T gets small as
delta T approaches zero then I can write
this as the derivative of the vector R
the time derivative I should say the
magnitude of the time derivative of
vector R and that's equal to the length
R times the time derivative of the angle
D theta DT but D theta DT is just the
angular velocity so I could write that
as R times capital Omega for the angular
velocity and this is just our familiar
result that for
circular motion for the rotation of a
position vector the velocity is equal to
the radius of the circle times the
angular velocity of the rotation another
way of thinking of that is that the
magnitude of the rate of change of the
position vector which we call the
velocity is equal to the length of the
rotating vector R times the angular
velocity of the rotation but there's
nothing special about the position
vector that I used in order to do this
analysis so if instead of a position
vector I considered any vector so let's
say this is my rotational motion of a
vector that I'll call a so that's a at
time T and then at some later time
that's a of T plus delta-t this vector
is my Delta a I'll call this angle Delta
Theta and so the vector a is rotating in
that direction with an angular velocity
capital Omega now in the example I just
did my vector a is actually R of T ok
but so everywhere where I have an R here
I can just write an a this is now just
an arbitrary vector in space that is
rotating at an angular velocity capital
Omega and what we see using the same
analysis we would find that the
magnitude of the time rate of change of
the vector that's the rotating vector is
equal to the length of the rotating
vector which is a times D theta DT or in
other words the length of the rotating
vector time is the angular velocity of
the rotation that's true for any vector
okay this is a general result
equals our Omega is just a special case
of this general rule where in that case
by rotating vector is a position vector
but this is true for any vector that's
rotating in space in particular for a
rotating angular momentum for a rotating
angular momentum vector I have that the
magnitude of the time derivative of the
rotating angular momentum vector is just
equal to the length of the angular
momentum vector the magnitude of the
angle mentum times the angular velocity
of rotation now in addition in the
particular case of a rotating angular
momentum vector or any angular momentum
vector rather we know that the time
derivative of the angular momentum
vector is also equal to the torque
vector so I can set these two things
equal in the case of a rotating angular
momentum vector the magnitude of the
torque is given by the magnitude of the
rotating angular momentum vector times
the angular speed of rotation and that's
just using the general behavior of a
rotating vector in space